más del medio millón de personas están
confinadas ya en la provincia de
zheijiang el epicentro del último
rebrote de coronavirus en china de ahí
salen 44 de los 51 casos detectados hoy
en el país lo que eleva el balance a 200
la presencia de jan situado en la costa
oriental es clave en la economía
nacional no sólo por su capacidad fabril
sino porque de ahí parten el grueso de
las exportaciones hacia el resto del
mundo el último rebrote coincida más con
la temida llegada de la última variante
o micro a pesar de todo el blindaje que
impone en china son dos casos en los
últimos días el último se trata de un
hombre de 67 años que lleva del
extranjero y que como todos se había
tenido que someter a variados test antes
de volar y que tras aterrizar fue
confinado en un hotel durante dos
semanas donde volvía a dar negativo en
todos los pesos dio positivo en su
tercera semana cuando ya cumplía la
cuarentena domiciliaria el caso revela
la dificultad de protegerse de la última
variante lo que hace pensar que china no
va a relajar las restricciones de
entrada ni va a jubilar su política de
'tolerancia cero' a pesar de contar ya
con más del 80 por ciento de la
población vacunada